social media today we're seeing the best
of people represented on facebook happy
photos you know and that's great
want people to be happy but then we feel
maybe that we measure slightly lower
than that because people are only
showing us their public selves are we
writing only about these happy people
and were somehow terribly flawed but
they're better and they're more
accomplished
I think everyone's lying on Facebook and
I think the lies are interesting but
they are fantasy yes
they're almost like superhero versions
of ourselves there's a there's something
called Malibu Barbie I think which is
just it's an app and Malibu Barbie gets
put in all these different locations she
one night she's at a beautiful
restaurant one night she's and it's just
to say the world of what we're putting
up on Facebook it's just a fantasy it's
just like a fairy tale this is the life
we would we would like to live but it's
boring when you look at other people's
Facebook and they're in Bali or they're
there they're doing yoga and they're
beautifully posed we don't believe a
word of that stuff right it's it's all
fake if we were to post our real lives I
did an exercise in class where I had
said I will give you $20 if you take
your camera and to go take a picture of
your bathroom right now without moving
anything or take a picture of your
bedroom without moving anything the real
better no one will do it because it
looks awful their real bedroom but if
you put that up on Facebook people would
love it because that's how you really
live so real stories are about not the
fantasy Facebook but the compelling
stories would be if you took a picture
of yourself when you just got up you
took a picture of your bathroom the way
it looks right now that's fascinating
and the best storytellers give you those
personal wounds and that's why the whole
superhero genre of movies right now is
boring it's crashing it's burning
because people don't really identify
with superheroes unless you're 11 years
old
superhuman the only superhero movie
that's really succeeded in the last year
and the best one is guardians of the
galaxy and the reason is you've got 5
deeply wounded people who are all sick
but they start supporting the each other
and they heal during the course of the
movie now one of the Avengers movies
does that a little bit but most of the
other superhero movies fail Captain
America is a bore because he's just a
lot of muscles and he's a stoic he never
changes so these superhero stories that
are lining up from the studio's they're
falling and they're crashing and they're
burning one after the other unless they
have a personal embarrassing wounded
hero at the center who's really showing
us his wound that's the secret of a
great superhero movie but few studio
movies do that because the way studios
make their superhero movies now is they
don't even hire writers they think up
action sequences and then they test them
in Thousand Oaks movie theaters in the
afternoon of a weekday and if you like
the action sequence you say yes if you
don't you say no on these little meters
and they assemble those sets of scenes
as the entire movie and that's just not
going to give you a great film and but
they're crashing and burning now
personal stories are always what sell so
a studio is always feel like they found
a formula that doesn't require writers
they're always trying to take writers
out of the equation and make it simply a
product but products sell because
they're great stories sell because the
product in it is flawed right that's the
big difference you can't sell a story
like a product because products are
supposed to be perfect and great well in
a story it's about people's flaws and
their embarrassments and their pain and
that's how you make a great story and ok
so that so it's about what ceci was
saying earlier about
personal wounds every story that you
like as an audience is about that every
story is about that personal wound it
always it always has been it always will
be and that's all we do as story
teachers is we ask you what's the wound
of your hero and how does that wound how
do they compensate for that wound at the
beginning of the story because that
compensation are your seams here's an
example um I had a wound when I was a
teenager my mommy didn't love me and so
because of that I had body dysmorphia I
thought my lips were the size of Mick
Jagger and that was how my core wound
manifested itself so you can say well so
what Peter that's for a therapist couch
but the way it manifested itself in my
life was I hid in the bathroom to eat
lunch I wouldn't kiss a girl during the
day I wore white chapstick all to hide
my lips I stopped playing the saxophone
each one of those compensations for my
core wound is a great scene in a movie
you can see me hiding in a bathroom
unable to eat in front of other people
you can see me turning a lights out to
kiss a girl you can see me putting on
white lipstick chapstick because I
wanted my mouth to be smaller so if you
can't make up interesting scenes for
your movie or your television show you
gotta go into what wounded you and what
you're doing in secret to compensate for
that we all have secret lives and
they're all about compensating for our
wounds that's the action that will make
a great story whether it's film or
television and a lot of writers just
don't know what to say what does my
character do next look at your wounds we
all have ten or twelve and they will
guide you into actually making and
manufacturing compelling scenes
you